hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast please make sure you
subscribe that way you get the episodes
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this
is r u garbage sure is little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
we find if they go to be classy or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day
we're down here at auntie's basement ah
again gotta talk to your little business
sure what's up
you know her friend randy i i who i mean
who
in the neighborhood doesn't know randy
true anyway had a suggestion wanted to
throw it by you
okay if that's okay sure i'm listening
he was thinking
that when it's just you and me we call
them
family episodes okay but when we have a
returning guest
sure we call it company okay that sounds
that's a great idea
do you like that is that okay that's a
great idea i think i had last night but
that's just me
well i have to give this to you then
what's this it's an invoice for two
thousand dollars for consulting work for
randy from randy yeah
from randy enterprises yeah make checks
payable to h
foley that's weird destroy that he's in
between bankers
wiping off my fingerprints gang
my boy is across the table from me so
that's a family app
it's just me and the kipperino give it
up for my best pal the real ceo
of ru garbage give it up for kevin james
hey buddy what's up guys how are you
thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know as i know randy knows tony
knows foley knows t-bone knows
those numbers are true true
i thought we were going to go trudeau
a little [ __ ] acapella on you t-bone
throwing audibles over there i like it i
like god keeps you guessing
um also uh patreon.com you can sign up
you get bonus episodes of ayg you get
episodes of hard feelings
breakout hit at 20. do you think this is
cooking hard feelings is [ __ ] this on
steroids
i'm start talking about gwyneth paltrow
for season two it's heating up over
there
uh and then also uh we're gonna be
posting footage of the live shows
on patreon t-bones cooking them up uh
you'll be getting
uh it'll be the parts of me and foley
closing out the show together we just
posted the raleigh
game baby the big game we posted the
nashville uh
footage today shout out today so you'll
see it shout out to zanies and we'll be
posting them as we do them so another
reason to add up and everybody gets
those on every level yes
that patreon is [ __ ] vega hire
cooking
cook put the help wanted sign out front
yeah also a couple of shows we got to
talk about
we do got to talk about a couple of you
shall we bring in t-bone let's get let's
get the rest of
the business out of the way so the
business is this we've uh we've crunched
the numbers we looked it over we had to
map out we had the boys on the coast on
the phone
i just picture a big map with like a
truck driving
a dotted red line it's just stars for
every shonies across america
ah here's a skinny chicago sold the [ __ ]
out how many shows did we sell out
we got two shows june 24th we're doing
two shows there's any chicago any
tickets left
there's no tickets no tickets not for a
fat kid or a skinny guy
doesn't matter early and late show are
both sold out now so what we did
what did we do we we added a third show
tuesday
january june 22nd wow
the tuesday before that for that seven
o'clock show
that's halfway sold out hate to tell you
by the time this it's probably it's
probably cooked by the time this comes
out so
get them ticks get the [ __ ] tickets
guys cause we gotta add another one
we gotta add another one we'll do it do
you think i won't add a [ __ ]
thing you listen you guys know me you
think i won't add another [ __ ] show
you choose okay you choose
and i heard it's a meal per show
everybody saw
everybody and then also atlantic city
sold out that first show uh so we had on
june 8th june 18th friday june 18th sold
out the early show i think it was an
eight o'clock show
sold that the [ __ ] out going to 10 30.
so we added a 10 30 show
yeah i'm hoping to sell that the [ __ ]
out
and also city in the summer time ain't
nothing wrong with it
indeed we're going to be in indianapolis
uh indiana is that right indianapolis
indiana a lot of eye wars flying around
i'm not confident enough in my midwest
geography however you spell it we're
tanking over there
let's move a couple of ticks in indy all
right folks if you live near [ __ ] i
don't whatever's by it
get in the car let's drive to see the
boys get to the nitty-gritty huh
chicago's got a motor on it ac's got a
motor
if you have relatives know anybody in
the indy area yeah let's just say we're
behind on the poles
you know what i mean everybody likes an
underdog folks
come out and see us helium comedy club
indianapolis indiana yeah
thank you guys so much for that how
about a nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the man the myth the
legend over here
thomas benjamin wilkerton
mcmullen that was not right what was
wilkerson wilkerson wilkinson's oh man
god sounds like you own a dairy company
when i got an uncle who stole my
inheritance
i don't know how they connect with all
right
is that true 100 really oh big time
really yeah spicy over there at the
mcmullen yeah should have you on
sometime and talk about it
what do you steer your tractor what
could you have inherited from your bozo
family yeah no
[ __ ] my grandfather you did really well
the textile industry had a whole bunch
of cash that away and that got spent on
a lifted truck in myrtle beach
wait how much traffic how much cash
could have been there when it got blown
on a lift yeah dropped yeah was it solid
gold
hold on your grandfather made a little
cash in the textile industry that's
correct
and how do you know this money was
allocated for you because it was
allocated for my entire family
my grandmother got dementia my scumbag
uncle signed over power of attorney from
her
and [ __ ] jacked the whole kitten
caboodle wow i respect it you gotta
i mean that guy's playing chess you
bozos were all [ __ ] fringier
yeah no kidding you guys are your
progressive schools watching npr
drinking martinis
this guy was [ __ ] playing hardback
yes guys playing for keeps
yeah and speaking of stealing uh if
anyone if any listeners have any music
that make any music any bands or
anything like that
and they're cool with us using their
tunes and and the edits we're doing on
the road
yeah send me a dm at towingmullen on
instagram toby.com on instagram
and i'll check your [ __ ] out also drop
and follow
sure yeah t-bone could you we could
juice t-bones numbers a bit my numbers
as well while we're [ __ ] at it at
kevin rancom
we got a couple of [ __ ] talented
listeners i got t-bones turned into a
record mogul yeah right i'll check it
out
over there t-bone enterprises yeah i
send it over to the a and r i'll have my
guide
they already played one for us she's
like you gotta hear these guys dude they
rip i'll [ __ ] shout them out right
now
these dudes [ __ ] daisy chain they're
[ __ ] awesome
daisy chain there you go alrighty we
love it
uh thank you t-bone we love you very
much gang family episode just me and
kippy
wanna throw a curve ball at you ask you
a quick question i'm ready
the shower has been greatly discussed
here in in in totti's we've talked about
the shower
shower etiquette brushing your teeth how
you shower what you shower with
um uh i'm from now on i'm going all
hands my hand scrubbers i really found
out the exfoliating hand scrubbing
i have these gloves that are like
exfoliating gloves that like really get
in there man they really exfoliate
that's what it's all about i think
because i have all these gonna be
showering with gloves on that's not true
it's more like industrial
listen i have all these little fat guy
things like not moles but like just
little things on my skin and when i use
that for a week they all start to go
away
so i'm going to keep rocking with that
but that's not my the business i wanted
to discuss with you sir
i just lost my appetite for a month what
our targeted ads on instagram must be
[ __ ]
nuts yeah it's all like industrial
cleaners and stuff oohs
sign up for these two barrels of ooze
shipped directly and discreetly to your
house every month
i'm not gonna lie i see a lot of billy
mays a lot of [ __ ]
sign up for oohs this will take the
shine off your coat
listen my whenever so if you turn my
shower on i get the shower warmed up
i've showered in your shower have you
i haven't no i'm not in the new
apartment oh no i have it yeah
um so when you shower sure
i'm like kramer when you go to work
should do me a favor take the trash out
every once in a while
help the old man out busting my balls
all the time
step up to the plate listen when i
so when if i turn my shower on to you
know get it warmed up while i do my
business
you know i don't know if you do that i i
turn the shower on and get it hot i do
my business and then when i'm done
i get in the shower you following what
i'm saying sure we've talked about this
i don't like to go in depth in what your
business is i assume it's not your taxes
i believe we're speaking
about the dumping jumper
hey if you want to get all military
about it sure
i've never heard that that's
just a drill sergeant next to the toilet
go go go go
go when you see that green light that
means go two wipes only two wipes
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] that's good well that i mean
that's not i don't have a name for that
that's just that's a fully s
that's in the first page of the playbook
on the foley's
everybody did that you telling your mom
was doing dumping jumps
no way dude no way mayo was like 37
doing dumping gym when you're getting
ready to go out that's what you do you
do your business and you get in the
shower and you come out you're all
cleaned up and fresh
i don't i'm on a different schedule
really yeah
oh man anywho um so i have this uh
like dead man switch on my toilet for
some reason what is a dead man
things go sideways it's an eject button
hit it you just go up you go up into the
fourth floor
you kill some poor schmuck who was
brushing his teeth sorry man it got
heavy down there
goose
[Laughter]
great balls of fire
we got a hot one here folks
ah i got the giggles i apologize
when you first love when i get your
number it's so easy just if i can keep
you giggling
it's like it's like tickling a baby
[Laughter]
that's so easy anyway
i have this thing if i flush my toilet
all of a sudden my shower stops
i don't know why it just because you're
living in a hellhole
i mean come on the water you're doing
you're making a little bit of cash move
into the island
moving the man listen the the the
faucet will still run but the shower
will turn really well it sounds like the
[ __ ] ritz
it's a great shower though it's humble
water pressure i wouldn't trade it for
the world i'm scared to move
that's how good the water pressure is
that's what happened we had decent water
pressure in my first apartment
new apartment like commando 3000 i can't
it's better oh yeah i couldn't do it got
the big round like
not waterfall but it's like probably
eight inches wide like the big circle
just i need i need heavy
heavy bikes i need it yeah i mean it's
strong otherwise it's nothing
um however so it does that okay and it
does it sometimes by itself
anyway long story short my question is
is this garbage
because it happened today we're not off
to a good start so probably
it happened today and i think i'm going
to keep doing it on my own
i was in there i had my gloves on i got
my [ __ ] beekman's 1802 [ __ ] goat's
milk soap i'm [ __ ] going to work on
myself
goat's milk and how to declare how to
unclassify a [ __ ] classy product
goat's milk milk milk gold goats milk
goat goat milk yeah i'm saying goats
anything with goat's milk
is classy classy yeah how you say milk
it's really big scratchy yeah goat's
milk
you all got any goats milk milk anyway
so y'all got any almond milk
yeah get out of here bozo i'm an oat
milk man
listen um i was in there and i was live
there and about halfway lathered up
you know and it killed it it it it quit
the shower the shower stopped they kept
the the drain keeps running you know the
water
you can't turn a drain off what do you
mean the drain keeps running no like the
faucet keeps running that would fill up
the tub whatever the [ __ ] that's called
that's on too
so you got that cooking no no no that's
off when you pull the button down
hold on all right hold on you're in the
shower shower's coming out of the top
yes you got your gloves your knee pads
your elbow pads off
[Laughter]
mo i'll be up in the bathroom playing
roll the hockey
line change dump and chase dump and
chase kid
[Laughter]
oh man yes we don't
every shower is the same when the
faucet's running the shower is not right
okay so when you
so sometimes mine will just cut off and
then the shower will stop and the water
will start
so when the toilets the turlets flushed
when your turret's flushed the shower
stops and the spout comes on
like the bathtub yes yes yes yes that's
what happens
you got to get a super in there or
something call a plumber that ain't
right and when you turn the lights on
the dishwasher
and the dog barks
don't turn the blender on i don't want
to see what happens goddamn places booby
traps
[Laughter]
i'm over here trying to [ __ ] catch a
hot shower [ __ ] taking paint cans to
the head
[Laughter]
low bridge holy [ __ ] so
it kicks off halfway through and the tub
comes on and a tub comes off so my
piggies are still getting warm
and there's still water going but then i
realized
when i start soaping up why don't i turn
the water off
and then i get myself really really
soapy
i do it and then turn the shower back on
that was what i was trying to say well i
think you're
is that crazy is that trash or is that
cliff it's not trash it's not clear
yours is a different issue i
do the same i think most people are in
the shower they got a little more space
than you do to maneuver
right square footage wise sure that's
what i'm saying so like i
wet myself right no gloves sands gloves
and i do my thing
and then i step out first of all i put
my ham shout out to you you step
out not out of the shower out of the
water so i can lather up like the
water's like maybe hitting my legs or
something over here
doing my biz okay getting the lather the
gooch whatever you need
you really gotta hit two or three places
that's all you got you gotta hit the
armpits
see i yeah you gotta you're obviously
you're an exception to the rule
yeah i have to maintain because i got to
think about what's the situation going
to be like
three hours from now when i'm sitting
next to somebody in that fat guy
as it's me typically it ain't good that
fat guy funk starts
starts taking the baseline for a walk
fat guy funk who's that bruno mars
you need to get showered like rambo
that's a [ __ ] deal
i would actually love that does that
happen to me every day
like [ __ ] gen pop intake as long as
as long as the order was worn you had to
have like four people scrubbing me with
scrubbers ah
probably he's probably so clean you're
going the wrong way you're going the
wrong way
i understand but you're going the wrong
way we have to have a serious
sit down get a couple of handlers over
at my house um
yeah and you step out of the water so
you're not and then you get in and rinse
off
i think you're just a little you're a
little tight yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i feel like you get
cleaner because a lot of times the soap
is getting washed off the scrunchie or
the gloves or whatever
it is about yeah yeah i think you're
just
i've been trying you can't even shower
normally i've been i've been trying to
push for one of those
curtains that go out a little bit you
ever see them in the hotel they bow out
a little bit
the ring yeah it gives you a little more
room or i really do stop it
i really want to see the dimensions of
your glasses we need to change the
dimensions of you
or just turn the whole bathroom into one
big shower oh man
the laziness we have to figure this out
there must be a solution to this yeah
stop to mcdonald's
by the way i caught you with a couple of
bags of mickey d's bags rolling around
in the back of your car the other day
they're old
that's nothing come on ah
it's nothing paddy's lying just so you
know
no i'm not patty take the car away from
him that's how he got back that's what
she told me
she's like this is like a year and a
half ago that's what she's doing yeah
she goes he's getting big
we got to do something i go i know patty
i break his bulls every day i'm making a
career i'm calling his fat pizza [ __ ]
fat
and she goes inside i'm doing my part
i'm making fun of him
hey one man can only do so much it takes
a village
whether you encourage him at all i
encourage him that he's disgusting
[Laughter]
ah that's too good um but
she goes it's when i gave him the car he
don't walk nowhere no more
[ __ ] yeah sometimes you don't even walk
to the car i seen you take an uber to go
i've seen you i've seen you take an uber
together let me tell you something
you'll take that car away from me
over my cold dead fat body
i love that goddamn thing i feel like
[ __ ] michael j
fox zipping around the city i put all my
stuff in the [ __ ] passenger seat
i love that move got all your stuff
right in the past you don't have stuff
i got stuff like shades water bottle
some burning
[Laughter]
hey gang quick announcement from our
sponsor hellofresh with
hello fresh you get pre-measured
ingredients and mouth-watering seasonal
recipes
delivered right to your door baby you do
you skip the trips to the grocery store
like a bozo and you can count on
hellofresh to make home cooking fun
easy and affordable that's why it's
america's number one
meal kit not number two not number three
numero
uno uh hello fresh cuts out the
stressful meal planning grocery store
trips so you can enjoy cooking and
getting dinner on the table in about 30
minutes or less
it's easy peasy i hate going to the
store fighting with the old bag about it
with this it's all cut out you can try
meals ready in 20 minutes or less
lightening prep recipes and quick
breakfast lunches and perfect for your
busy schedule big man
let me tell you this as you know we each
got one they sent us one
fantastic big box of stuff big box of
stuff i show up
yesterday at my apartment hellofreshbox
is right there
go inside show my girl she's gushing
over it uh-huh
my lady liked it too it's a big package
we got a pork dish
we have a chicken dish and we have a
shrimp dish last night
cajun shrimp over kale salad
with smoked pineapple um
pickled onions and crunchy sweet
potatoes you're gonna be ready for beach
season that big guy
everything's there everything's chopped
up she had this in there
boom boom boom put it together in two
seconds i'm telling you
unbelievable yeah guys it's a home run
so go to 100 honest fantastic
go to hellofresh.com garbage12
and use promo code garbage 12 for 12
free
meals you got to try it man 12 free
meals what are we doing we're talking 5
10 i'm talking 12 free meals and they
stuff you they ain't skimpy either
including free shipping so one more time
guys go to hellofresh.com
garbage12 use promo code garbage12 get
your 12 free meals and free shipping hey
guys
another quick word from our sponsor the
good folks over there at
helix send another bed hey guys the guys
at uh helix sent us a sent me a mattress
sent another one the boss got the
mattress me and the lady
loving it that's what i keep hearing we
had a bozo one from ikea like idiots
it was not comfortable this is the first
nice mattress i have
come on guys uncle hank it's a game
someone for the big man it's not an
extra big one for the big
uh i didn't know what i was missing out
on sleeping on a terrible mattress you
know what i mean
once they sent it it's a proper game you
feel like you're floating
my brother has one they rave about it i
know it's very nice
so get rid of your dirty stained one
whatever you got going on
and get involved with helix uh here's a
couple of things that helix wants you to
know check this out
helix sleep has a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete
and matches your body type to the sleep
preference that's perfect for you
yep that's their secret like why would
you buy a mattress
that's meant for somebody else you
wouldn't with helix
you're getting the mattress that's
designed perfectly for you based on this
quiz
everybody's unique helix knows that all
right so they have several different
mattresses
different mattress models that you can
choose from yeah they got soft they got
medium they have firm mattresses
they have mattresses that are great for
cooling you down at night when you're
hot when you sleep
and they even have a mattress for plus
size
sleepers like the big dog for the big
man
guys i i took the quiz me my wife took
it and asked it's really easy to ask you
a couple of questions what you like what
you prefer how you sleep
we got the twilight model got a chip
comes in a box
boom you pop it open it's like two hours
or something and needs to set and then
boom
right off the field great sponsor right
off to
sleepytown or whatever so go to
helix.com garbage take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you with a customized mattress and give
you the best sleep of your life i'm
telling you it is a game
changer they have a 10 year warranty and
you don't need to
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights risk
free
ain't nothing to lose and they'll even
pick it up for free if you don't like it
but you will guys so one more time
they're offering 200
off of mattress order look out for our
listeners plus
a free pillow if you go to helix.com
garbage
200 bucks you can't afford to not buy
this if you're in the mattress for a
market check out helixsleep.com
garbage get up 200 off and two free
pillows
gang spring is here oh yeah and summer
is right around the corner it's time to
get back outside
and start exploring the outdoors and
you're going to want to do that with a
box of
awesome from bespoke post to upgrade
your life yep whether you're out there
taming the wilderness or you're taking
your home bar to a pro
level heights bespoke post only sends
guys the best stuff
every single month no matter what you're
into box awesome has everything and has
you covered
from style and grooming goods to bar
wear to cooking tools
to outdoor gear box of awesome has
collections
for every single part of your life yeah
guys if you're not familiar it's cool
guy [ __ ]
it's stuff it's stuff you want that you
need that you don't know you want or you
need and you don't know where to get it
bespoke post is right for you we got a
knife we got a hammock we got a tent
good night yeah we got uh something else
it's you got a duffel
a doll that tuffle is that duffel is
something else too
um so to get started he's bench pressing
450 now
so to get started go to box of
awesome.com your ansel take the quick
quiz the answers will help you pick the
right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a bunch of different categories
it's free to sign up you can skip a
month you can put it on pause whatever
you want to do
cancel any time each box only costs 45
but has over 70 worth of gear inside and
also one of our listeners reached out
one of the things they have on the
website is a toothbrush holder and
toothpaste holder
for the shower oh there we go
if you're a real piece of trash or get
involved with bespoke post you get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com
enter our promo code garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome.com
promo code garbage for 20 off your first
box
now back to the show all right that's a
that's a pretty good segue
um guys this is a fam episode so as you
know when you sign up for the patreon
uh we will read your garbage questions
there's a [ __ ] influx holy doesn't
like me saying that but we have a
backlog i just want to let everybody
know we're getting to everybody
um sometimes we got to pick and choose
what's right for the guests so not we
you know if you join that week we might
not be able to get to it right away but
we're getting to everybody
and we're cleaning house so we've gotten
through a lot there's only a handful
still hanging around um but that being
said this is from kevin jacobs
have either of you left a bernie in an
ashtray outside of a gas station while
you went in to retrieve it upon exit
because people have i've heard this
question a little bit different
it's usually not an ashtray it's on the
sill like on the windowsill of the
whatever
yeah um yes right here i i've definitely
done it
how do i feel about it you've done it
you've left it why not just enjoy the
bernie that's what i don't get
i don't know because any my whole
relationship with smoke no there's no
logic to it
you know what i mean there's there's no
like oh i'll sit and enjoy it
[Music]
i gotta get in there and go like a
squirrel on meth
that's one of your bits always looking
around a decade ago
yeah man yeah you can be a tough hang
sometimes but a lot of people are like
that they're they want to do their
mission
you know what i mean i see people do it
with cigars the thing that grosses me it
doesn't gross me out in the moment
but when i'm walking in the 7-eleven if
i'm not smoking and i see an
old one not one that somebody's
currently burning that's been there
yeah like a cigar that that they never
went back for you know what i mean for
whatever reason got hemmed up got him
they started working there they never
left well at the back i don't know what
happened
but when you see one of the any
cigarette that's
that looks like it's been rained on
instantly turns me off
well when we were kids i you know we
grew up i grew up in the suburbs of
philly and i was a skateboarder so there
was a lot of shopping center hangs right
that's what we did
we went to the shopping center who are
you skateboarding with
i think i mean you want the name the
guys that are tony hawk the guys
i mean what what answer do you think i'm
going to give you here that you're going
to be satisfied with you wouldn't ban
margera
i'm kippy james ryan no no no no squad
that i know the boys they weren't skate
punches
really we all skated yeah yeah all right
his name is
flip yeah flip i could see i didn't
think flip pat
flip yeah all my friends from high
school we all skated all through the big
guys
the big guy wasn't out there right phil
no he's a college friend yeah yeah yeah
yeah no he's a little more refined yeah
guys
gentlemen suit and tie to work he ain't
[ __ ] dean doing all that in the story
this kid floats in a couple different
worlds you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah classy one minute but i
mean skateboarding i mean skateboarding
as a kid is in trouble i mean we were
trash
yeah whatever so we'd go hang out at uh
at the krauser like at this shopping
center what's it called
krauser's i think yeah have you ever
said that to me
[Laughter]
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah it was a tough
one it was a real
sounds like a british insult a bunch of
crabs as they are
a couple of crowds isn't it whole lot of
them all crowsers i tell you
what the [ __ ] bad day at the football
pitch by the crowds
yeah sounds like a gang oh no it's the
krauses
the peaky blinders are fighting on
tuesday yeah i hear that's season six
tommy versus the grouselers
no one touched these muffins in the name
of the krauses
i ordered a [ __ ] crabs dude i didn't
know you were the crowsers
yeah i think that's what it was called
the crowd chryslers chrysler i think we
said just change it to acme
yeah it was a tough look it was the top
trying to keep the lease in here
tough tough look um but we would hang
where were we going with this oh so we i
you know as as if when you have parents
who smoke smoking's way
like you know what i mean it's not this
like weird thing so we all like wanted
to smoke as kids
she's like that's what adults do adults
smoke and drink don't smoke and drink
and i really lived up to that one really
[ __ ] hitting home runs on that i saw
one of my little cousins pouring
champagne the other day i was like
that's not going to be good yeah yeah i
i got
i have like a couple of cousins like the
younger they were like it's so funny
when to see now we'll go to a family
party
we're boozers like we are boozers
through and through
like the kids start yeah you've met them
right
there's always someone's got someone's
in a headlock someone's getting noogied
and then to see to be at the family
party like easter and like there was
like
you know young teenage girls were like
oh we're going around to the corner to
go get a whatever and then they all got
like caught with like white claws or
whatever
really yeah you're like oh dude imagine
wait you had a bust on [ __ ]
on easter i mean we weren't sending the
swat team man that's pretty
yeah that should have been a story
though you look the other way
i mean it's we had a very uh
understood thing which it was kind of
like if you had your license you could
drink which is kind of counterintuitive
a bit
but you could booze early and it's just
an understanding like the roosevelt
marriage
yeah we had an open relationship with
booth
yeah if you're if you're old enough to
die for your country
you're old enough to drink oh dude she's
15.
i could sign her over yeah yeah oh we
were big like you can have a [ __ ]
yeah you can have a cocktail not like it
wasn't celebrated
at the family party but it's just one
more thing swept under the rug
yes if they if they were smart enough to
go to one of the houses that was empty
around the corner
and you know dip into the white claws or
whatever i mean no one's [ __ ]
tracking them down
it is what it is um but
what did i forget how that started but
we would hang out a crowsers back to the
crowds
back to the crowsers uh and we wanted to
so we'd be skating and you would see
guys walk in and like flick a cig like a
half of
a bernie or whatever you'd scoop it i
wouldn't but like my boys would
like raw enough [ __ ] grab it take a
couple of dragon and everything like
dude what the [ __ ] come on man i'll
steal them from my dad if we want him
that bad
yeah yeah that's a it's a tough tough
look it's a tough look
yeah um especially how people smoke
differently
like a couple of my boys they take it
like like it's a hit and bass stone
they're just
they take like a hard yeah then they
give it back to you it's what they're
what you call
darts it's the filter's coming off a
little bit you're like what the
[ __ ] are you doing it's hot yeah i don't
like that
yeah yeah like a nice cool bernie
i like my bernie's room town put them in
the freezer for a minute
uh this next one question this next one
hasn't come up yet
which is crazy yeah this is crazy to me
that hasn't come up
uh this is from ba and this is from bob
shout out to big big
and i think it's application is it trash
if you grew up with a bar in your
basement
well this is very this is very at how
it's done
and why it's done i feel like because
growing up we didn't have one
we'd go over to my my dad's like our
family friend's house and they had
they had like a real nice wooden one
with like the sink behind it
and we to us that i might as well been
in a tgi fridays baby i was hanging the
[ __ ] out
asking for the specials a couple of my
ties for me and the boys
if your family had a fully stocked bar
it'd just be vermouth by the end of the
night
yeah that's pretty much oh yeah yeah
yeah well yeah we never had it and i
always wanted one
i feel if it was a finished basement
with the bar with a nice
if it was done nice for like parties
i feel it was classy but i'm also
i come from dirtbag alcoholics so i
can't call it
i would have to say overall no matter
how nice they are
to how shitty they are overall you would
have to say if we're being honest with
ourselves
it's trashy that being said i don't
agree
that being said fantastic
well it's for entertainment purposes
which is classy if you're having people
over and you want to be able
here you can have a bottle of wine you
have this you could have that hell else
would you be doing
just hanging out on a tuesday
hey barkeep two more huh a little slow
tonight
i thought there'd be more foot traffic
yeah it's your basement dude
um i say that as a kid who had one i was
born
tell you something you use the washing
machine what are you talking about
in the early 80s we didn't all right
mountaintop pennsylvania my parents
first house the house that i was born in
every time you say mountaintop
pennsylvania i was saying top of the
muffin tree
talk about clean living up there a
couple of [ __ ] summers fantastic
they had a finished basement that had
a bar that was i would say as long as
the studio
they had this bar put in when you came
down the steps in your basement
dude when you came down the steps you
walked by it to get into the living room
but it was huge
okay and huge bar that's where we had
the kegerator we had an old refrigerator
that had a [ __ ] keg in it
they hooked the lines up they had draft
beer [ __ ] sinks refrigerators yeah
but i bet it was all milwaukee's best in
old crow
all right yeah it was just fram y
apologize it was the early 80s
which is trashy i feel what if we were
serving [ __ ] cocktails and snifters
it'd be any better
you give the people what they want i
wasn't entertaining the [ __ ]
the royal family yeah you play the hits
yeah what are you talking about the high
heat
couple a couple of pbr's and [ __ ]
well whiskey all dark plywood
the the that ply if your bar's made out
of plywood that's true
dark wood whatever you want to call it
all right i don't know what particle
board it was
it was an old entertainment set just
foam cooler
no but all around the bar my dad had
like uh like
padding like but like nice nice leather
like so
the fake leather pants i know when you
put your elbows on it was soft
clean living well dude the parties were
christmas whatever
it was like you were in a bar you didn't
need to go a lot
of those bars and i grew up with family
like friends having them they were very
uh uh like uh vfw
feel 100 that's exactly what it felt
like it feels like you're in a clubhouse
not a house or a ball and not a bar it's
not a house it's a clubhouse my dad or
somebody would be back there bartender
so there became like a scene
at the bar like people were at the bar
of course and the living room was right
there there was a screen door that went
outside deck upstairs
nice this is a big this is a big
question were there any neon signs or
any or any like
budweiser like signs because that's gore
there might have been one or two but
this was the early 80s when those were
that was hot that was like an iphone
yeah yeah yeah
dude [ __ ] classy yeah
we we never had i always i mean but then
i look at like you know
shout out to our uh our boy c myers
yes his come on that's like a pub that's
like you're going to like [ __ ]
that's like a fishbone grill yeah
everything's marble and nice
that's what i'm saying but yeah but i'm
saying either way there's still an
element of
a little bit of garbage to that or maybe
not garbage you know that's a very
old-school thing to do
i don't think it's trash i think if it's
done i think it's done
properly it's not trashy that's just me
but i i think it's very
by uh i'll tell you what i there is this
i want one oh yeah when i get a basement
i'm getting a bar
we should put one in here i have a
bartender the whole time
my uncle had one that was like a little
mini one like one that you would almost
like see it like at like a wedding it
was like
kind of move oh dude wait my aunt has
one that we still it goes to like house
to house whenever we have parties yeah
it's big and heavy and plastic and that
you can put
but it looks like wood but it's all
plastic and like it has a sink
that you fill with ice and then that
drain it's like very and we'd like
oh who's patty's doing easter it's going
to patties it's going here
that's pretty nice it's going to carols
yeah my uncle red had one like that same
with the with the
with like the foam around it it was real
nice and it would usually be bare
and then when the holidays kicked in it
like popped out and came to life there'd
be like things on there some stencils it
was like right in the dining room
[ __ ] class okay fantastic the
counterpoint could be i agree that it's
garbage because if your class you don't
have a bar you have a wine cellar
i grew up with friends with wine cellars
who's this guy
that's t-bone mcmuffin aka the magic man
uh yeah but not everybody likes wine
like if you have money and you're
relatively classy
a lot of people like [ __ ] cheap beer
and scratchers what do you think about
that
post it up at the bar it's also but like
i i don't know how to call this also in
my def
in your defense i guess i want a wine
cellar too don't get me wrong
not an animal filled with [ __ ]
zinfandel and [ __ ] you're gonna have a
walk-in humidor full of slim jibs
something from 88 please keep my hoagies
down there
keep my hoagies this is a gym
summer 2009. alex was working the grill
in you i guess your defense of our boise
myers
uh his when i was there in
his basement bar which it's like
fantastic we were just doing shots of
fireballs so there you go
trashy it's very trash
sure it's fantastic i guess if you did
have money and you were classy you would
have a wine cellar
i bet he has
he's got to have a wine cabinet or
something i'm yeah it's probably behind
the bar yeah
he's got like you know yeah yeah i mean
his looks like a [ __ ] tgi friday
it's a [ __ ] scene back there uh
basement bar
and a wine cellar there you go yeah
gotta have a hot tub somewhere close by
yeah i'm getting it yeah
i'm getting out of the city soon i've
decided yeah you have to have access
outside there's got to be a sliding
glass door somewhere around here too
foley's getting out of there
tea parties yeah i'm oh dude hot tub i'm
you you think i'm not getting a [ __ ]
hot tub yeah
yeah for sure for sure cut up time
machine
um this one this is from ren i'm not
really sure this
this can go either way i don't know if
he means all at the same time or just in
general
um did your family ever own multiple
dogs of only one breed
[Laughter]
because wait a minute you mean like two
golden retrievers yeah
which is kind of i so we we didn't do
them
that's classy i don't know i don't know
it depends at the same time we just kept
replacing patches patches was an english
springer spaniel and we just kept
replacing them
how many there was like three or four
patches that doesn't add up numbers-wise
there was something going on in there
before i was born
like still you're talking about 40 years
of dog right there
three dogs
what the [ __ ] is that well he's aged
seven times quicker
yeah than the ryan household well one or
two i think
we had to uh you know went to the farm
maybe
why the one was real the one was
the one was before my time i was a baby
but he was really bad
really bad my mom hated him hated him
then why'd you get the same kind of dog
and name it the same well then because
then my
dad sickos my dad got the patches i had
and my mom had rusty oh so they weren't
the same name
no not the same name though okay there
was a couple of pat no there we go
there was a couple of patches that's
weird there was at least two maybe three
patches no i think that's classy as [ __ ]
man it's always rich people you see with
like two golden retrievers two great
danes
two dalmatians some [ __ ] like that what
are you talking about
it's people they don't have golden
retrievers they have great danes it's
people that have like
three and four all different dogs
they're the ones that's garbage dude my
whole so my neighbor so i we
looks like a [ __ ] street gang we've
been kicking the tires on a couple of
puppies
right and uh we're on the fence because
we got a lot of travel coming up this
summer so i'm like can't give it back
i'm not going to give it back [ __ ]
aspca shut the [ __ ] up
yelling at me about what i can and can't
do with a puppy all these people are
giving them back on that yeah you said
this before i'm not going to get you
shut up will you um get a nice dog
this is like the third time you've
yelled at me not to return a puppy i
don't own yet
so what's my new charity the woman who
lives next to me she walks don't she
watches dogs
in the apartment so she's like uh
i was like oh i got in the i got in the
elevator with a bunch of high rollers in
that building
i got in the apartment with i got in the
uh i got in the elevator with you got a
tires guy in there too and she's got
like uh she's got like six
[ __ ] dogs and they're all like and
she's like oh
and then the next day she only had one
she had her dog which is like a little
wiener dog
lost a couple huh i go oh she goes yeah
we got she's like
you know he's happy he's all back alone
like she's like my dog's happy he's by
himself now we're not like boarding
these other two or three dogs or
whatever she does it right there in her
place
yeah so then get this dude he's got six
dogs
[ __ ] it dude listen to this so then
she's like yeah he was getting jealous
that the big dog kept stealing his
place in bed and i'm like
[Music]
in bed with me and i'm like what you're
sleeping with these rando dogs
i'm like this is bananas and then i go
oh look at the foot of the bed she goes
no right on my head
i'm like you're a lady you're sleeping
with other people's dogs on your
forehead
is [ __ ] insane insane dude
that's bananas i don't even like petting
other people's dogs let alone having
this [ __ ] gooch in my face
it's no good man i wouldn't want my dog
staying there
[ __ ] house of sin [ __ ] puppy orgy
going [ __ ] caligula over there and i
don't think so
dude i was walking a pit bull one time
and this guy came up and was like blue
nose pit
i got one too and pulled his iphone out
show me some photos like they make some
good babies
i was like are you trying to pimp your
dog to me right now dude i'm so weird
so weird he was he was literally like we
could make a little cash
i was like this is not my dog the dog
has the lipstick out
so do i not too shabby huh
um all right this one's from breadstick
ever have an
office chair in the living room or
family room aka wherever the tv is
that is the definition of a tough look
it was never started out there no but it
was definitely missing a wheel
dragging around that one needed a
doughnut
i would i i would so does foley
i would rather have the chair uh missing
the wheel than the wheel that always
comes out because every time you move it
it slides out
it's [ __ ] like a jerk off yeah like a
jerk off
we never we never had the we never had
had uh a random chair
sometimes that was the best chair in the
house because it was comfortable to sit
in
we'll be one you're watching your shoes
if your computer a lot of times the
computer was in people's family rooms
especially in the 90s oh man
if there wasn't a lot of room it would
be like in the back of the family rooms
like behind the couch or something those
little [ __ ] computer stands or like a
little desk
yeah looking you were starting microsoft
i mean
you got so many pictures of dad's
sitting in front of like an epson
in the [ __ ] yeah chair propped up
with paperback
yeah not knowing what the [ __ ] they're
doing if you got an office chair sitting
on blocks you're in a bad way
that's bad too and then also the people
that like the home
if you i had a buddy who his was in his
family room right the computer was in
the family room desktop right
yeah of course i mean this is like dude
you're getting a dell this is like you
know mid-90s you should have saw the
computer i went to college with
holy [ __ ] man it took like four guys to
carry it in
it was an it was an epson [ __ ]
something
salt
and epson epic i think it was and just
to get like the word processor up to
like type up a report or how to have
somebody
stationary it took like three floppy
disks
floppies to [ __ ] juice it up that was
when those little hard jaws came out
everybody else had them
the hard those little hard discs
remember the ones that's free
what were they three and a half or
something they were called yeah they
said a little piece of metal would slide
over it looked like something from like
strange days or something i'm not sure i
know you're yeah that's a floppy disk
no floppies are floppy those were hard
disks oh the hard disk yeah see look at
that there you go
yeah with the metal thing i thought dude
i thought i was in [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying yeah
yeah i'd be like look i'll open it i
don't care
i'm a [ __ ] badass dude [ __ ] out of
here dude
that's so funny ryan's gone rogue
he's exposed to just the air he took
oregon trail outside the library
he's a madman that number muncher shout
out to number monster
that was an old one more of a butt
muncher man
[Laughter]
what you doing is your business sir
this is a [ __ ] family program okay
this one i mean some are just home runs
this is from pete caho
uh ever buy shampoo by the gallon
well that's why i asked kim when we had
kim on i know
why how big was the detergent you get
because i feel like the bigger you get
of something
the trashier it is like my mom has like
literally like a 40 gallon drum
of some off-brand detergent downstairs
she knocks it out of the park don't get
me wrong sure i don't know how
off-brand detergent's a tough look but
what my mom i don't know if they still
make them and i think my mom has moved
at least down the shore she's moved to
pods specifically
but she's a tide she's a tide broad
through and through yeah
but she used to have the big jug of tide
like
yeah where you pour it with the spout on
draft yeah yeah she would have that 100
and we have a rack above the laundry
thing so it's just like a tap like you
don't have to move it of course yeah
they get the cut
that cup gets so disgusting oh a little
icky you gotta rub water under it
broad's gonna clean it up a little bit
over there yeah keep it tight how the
[ __ ] did t-bone go
oh the lights weren't on oh you goober
your job is the lights
no not over there on my side from now on
you're all lights
oh man yep
it's official huh i hate bending over to
do those ones over there you could use
the [ __ ] ab workout
the whole thing was like that way you
fit in the shower we got to get them on
the clapper
yeah yeah remind me after this episode
i'll order the clapper and then
beautiful uh what do you want to do or
start over
[Laughter]
hey everybody out there we just do it
line for line
reading that's a teleprompter all
cross-eyed and [ __ ]
yes my dad had a bar downstairs um
what do you got this one's from kristen
uh
have you ever used something not
intended for you loved it and now
use it in shame my husband used our
eight-year-old's toothpaste when we ran
out
and now he'll only use bubble gum
flavored kids toothpaste
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah that's 100
percent the same [ __ ] grit though
no it doesn't yeah it doesn't no it
doesn't do it it's made for teeth that
are going to fall out on their own i
know
yeah it's just loosening them up for you
yeah i think it is sugar just to loosen
up yeah
get it up in the root um
i mean every single one of my
girlfriend's beauty products
as far as like her it ain't working
it is though my skin is fantastic she's
got the
um you're just talking about all the
stuff you have on you what
what's with my exfoliation and this
stuff is cleaning it off
that's what i said that stuff's putting
it on there who knows
no no no uh
my dad back forget it
he used to use i used to use my dad's
deodorant
straight up but my dad used i remember
my dad used to use the johnson
johnson no tear shampoo really way back
in the day
tough guy i think his hair was like
he used to have a perm too my dad used
to go get burns that's awesome i used to
have perms and a big [ __ ] eight
i want wieners i tried to do a little
one in the quarantine
it just curls it curls it up t-bone
should get one tighten it would be able
to
we wouldn't be able to fit in here
we'd be up against the window [ __ ]
jackie moon over here
[Laughter]
you play for the tropics you're the
owner operator of the tropics
we're gonna try we're gonna trade fully
for a [ __ ] washing machine ah
man i don't care who you are
that movie's fantastic corndogs jackie
corndogs for everyone
man that was one of those movies where
it was before i had
cable in one of my college apartments
for like a month we kept putting it off
so i just had to watch that on repeat
and like go to bed with that on
you'd wake up the [ __ ] dvd extras
would be playing at like ten thousand
i hate oh dude i hate the tv playing
when you go to sleep
that's trash when you wake up and the
[ __ ] tv's on
i need it sometimes you do well no not
now anymore
gotta get away from hotel yeah i don't
want someone coming together
nuts the hotel tv is always on yeah yeah
you kidding me i turned the hotel when i
go to my mom's and i if i stay on the
couch and my mom's
i'll [ __ ] tv it for sure because
you're scared
it's a little it's a little quiet out
there in bucks county
yeah man i go back i don't want [ __ ]
freddie coming to get me is out there i
don't like sleeping in front of a
sliding glass door i can tell you that
well i heard that hole that whole room
is all
is all glass doors it's like you're in a
[ __ ] death box dude
you know it's like you're in an aquarium
for serial killers
[Laughter]
yeah there's just there's six of them
it's my turn tonight boys yeah man
that's a tough look
if i ever looked out and saw [ __ ]
somebody standing there i would [ __ ]
[ __ ] my pants oh then i start thinking
i'm like well it's always so scary when
they can see you and you can't see them
if you're inside and the lights are on
you're a sitting [ __ ] duck you're
better off cutting off all the lights
than hanging out in the dark
just talking about this where are we how
you were
i don't like it yesterday i came into
the studio i unlocked the door
lights are off and foley's just sitting
in the dark staring at the door going
hello toby it was like two minutes
before
but i told you i remember when i was a
kid every once in a while my old man
would
when he'd be if he was watching my mom
was working he'd kill all the lights in
the house turn the flood lights on
and we'd like sit on patrol like [ __ ]
in a little foxhole
right in front of the bay window way to
play a cool box
shout out to the big man doing overtime
keeping it safe baby but no that's when
he told me about the
when when when it's dark inside it's
when you have light shining you can't
see in
i don't like it well the other one i
like when the lights are off and you see
out
nice little sniper spot check the wire
make sure no one's coming through jesus
christ
flipping off cheers for that oh i gotta
have a jello pudding pop in my
in my stomach hey bozo can we play war
later i'm trying to finish my ice pop
here
he's telling me we're about to get
overrun
we don't have enough ammo to fight these
people anyway to wrap this up before
growing pain starts
oh it was great good stuff
we did the dogs with one breed that's
trash um
i mean not trash i think we might have
touched on this before this from casey
uh bringing your own koozies to a party
clean living or trash
dude come on trash trash use it on my
feet
is trash i feel like bringing bringing
your own anything that's just for you to
a party is garbage yes that's a trash
move
yes whether it's booze or whatever you
know what i mean
if you're going to a party don't bring
like just like i said oh i got a little
bit of myself
like my own and like drinking your own
thing it's just that's a weird tone
okay you're a guest the koozie now you
know exactly which beer is yours
yeah the one in your hand is it is it
really that big of a mystery and that
big of a thing
i like to know exactly which one's mine
who gives a [ __ ]
yeah i i never understood it we were
never a family of
it there was always like one normal
people okay there were like
radio giveaways normal people don't do
it if somebody does it i guarantee you
they're the weird one or something
there's something screwy about that i
feel like there's a positive correlation
between people that use beer koozies and
wear oakley sunglasses
bingo right yeah probably got like a lip
packed in or something
oakley sunglasses on top of their
baseball hat okay in what environment
is koozie appropriate i think a boat
causes fire
if they have them you don't bring your
own koozies on a boat are okay
koozies i think it like maybe
all right this is when i who the [ __ ]
taking that long the [ __ ] drink of
beer anyway
sure i don't know three minutes sure
trust me the first two you gotta get
through it
you gotta get up to speed you gotta get
across the river yeah real quick
uh i would say also if you were like
going somewhere where you shouldn't be
drinking as in like hey i'm not
flaunting this a little bit like if you
have the bottle koozie because you're
like walking
walking your dog or something at night
you're like i don't want to just be the
[ __ ] guy who looks like i'm drinking
in public it's a little it's a little
more subtle that i'm fine with but like
i don't what are we yeah i don't know a
lot of people are going to be upset
about this yeah kippy's out here putting
the silencer on the barrel
yeah exactly also i tried to sell them
one time i got the maid remember that i
got a little watermelon i got like 100
beer koozies made think i was gonna sell
them on the road
i think i got 98 still left in my
apartment you had a couple of hair brain
schemes before this took off
that's all that matters it's all that
matters kids are [ __ ]
cloudy with a chance of meatballs over
here i never saw nothing
i don't know i don't know it damn it
damn you kippy
damn you bad movie reverend yeah that
was a t-bone
that was a t-bone bad movie reference
that's what we're calling t-bones from
here honestly guys quote in lawrence of
arabia over here
you guys ever seen hackers i have of
cour gene hackman
no oh no with seth green i think right
i think you're thinking of can't hardly
wait no was hackers with ryan phillippe
and tim robbins
no i'm thinking of sneakers with river
phoenix and robert redford
angelina jolie you see your tits pg-13
i'm listening she had a nice little
derriere on her matthew it's a matthew
lillard joint
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes i do know
that who's matthew lillard
oh i know guys he's been in everything
you know exactly
he's in uh bad girls or good girls on
nbc's
i'll watch either one of them it's great
they're all great great show
all right let's see here something a
couple of more then we gotta wrap
her up i love this we've touched on this
before
but uh from kyle have you ever bought
new clothes because you didn't want to
do laundry shirts underwear socks etc
yeah that's how i ruined my credit at
macy's for sure
for sure that was a big one uh this
one's for matt
have you ever put coins on a train track
to make homemade pressed pennies
[Laughter]
i've played on train tracks yeah not
heavily trafficked ones
for some reason we knew better i think
all the ones by us were done
at that point it was a you you
when you the first time you play on
train tracks
you notice it and you know okay i've
crossed the line no matter how old you
are you realize you're [ __ ]
garbage yes because you know you
shouldn't be there
you know joe dirt easily somebody could
get killed yeah
all right foot gets caught in the
[ __ ] serpent but it was exhilarating
oh yeah you're playing with [ __ ]
dancing with the devil
i got like like a mixed group like a
couple of dudes couple of girls you know
what i mean like an older brother
younger brother it was like oh it's like
it was like a movie you know what i mean
when you were out
standing by me let's see oh yeah you
guys ever see the video of the russian
kids who
lay down and have the train go over them
no those russians they play by their own
rules man [ __ ] hand swim are you
garbage or are you russian that should
be in the next installment
i'm not doing anything that's gonna [ __ ]
up dinner that night i can tell you that
oh wait actually did you guys ever hear
that like if you did that if you put the
coins on the on the tracks that it would
derail the train
that was i think that was by like the
reading train company what's your
probably don't worry around but maybe it
could
i never wanted to do anything with that
either d-rail on a train
that's gotta be a felony right
i didn't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] yeah it was
at least intense yeah
no way i wasn't going near that yeah we
never really [ __ ] with my dad
my dad said he like they grew up they
would drive
on the train and then jump off the
bridge into the water like in roxboro
jesus yeah right took me the one time he
always told stories
not doing it but he told us stories like
and then we were like where was the
bridge and we were like in his old
neighborhood or like we were like
visiting my grandmom or something
and we stopped and we got out and we
walked i don't think it was running at
that point anymore but we walked down
like the trestle bridge
crazy and i was like dude i made it like
it was it was we had to like step
over there you walked over the truck
over something like you could have
fallen
yeah [ __ ] out dude i've made it like six
steps i'm like whoop all right i've seen
enough
i believe it let's go no way
not doing chick-fil-a still open let's
go
now [ __ ] that
yeah wasn't doing that tell you that
right now
didn't like any of that [ __ ] um all
right let's see this is from chelsea
have you ever
this i'm deferring to you this is more
your wheelhouse
politics economics poetry
what could it be um
this is from ts eliot i'm gonna be
embarrassed have you ever had a peanut
butter and maple syrup sandwich
at least i believe i have really like
just like like aunt jemima's on it
just to sweeten it up is that what it
does man i think i gotta be honest with
you
i don't think this was that long ago i
mean no one's shocked
you know what i think it was i had
peanut butter
like maybe like a quarter left peanut
butter in a jar
and i put some syrup in there and was
eating that like
wait hold on i zoomed i zoned out for a
second say that again
i think i had a jar of peanut butter and
it was like a quarter way filled
so it was like you know nice little
crevice in it and i put syrup in there i
was eating it like that like instead of
just
eating peanut butter with a spoon i was
eating peanut butter maple syrup you
somehow made it fatter
yes like a bear trap holy trap
you look at his head's in the bottle
yeah jeez what about what about a peanut
butter and honey sandwich
i was literally just gonna say that
[ __ ] right up there with the peanut
butter and jelly
no [ __ ] doubt about it one of my boys
brought it every day
it was peanut butter and [ __ ] honey
on uh like strowman's wheat bread
and by the time it got to lunch it would
like crystallize a little bit so there
was a little bit of a crunch in it
[ __ ] top shelf what kind of bread
were you showing up
you didn't mention strobes we were a
strowman's family we were
and then my dad moved to the italians
like mart
martinelli's or something martin
martinelli's is the is no it's not
martin's like potato roll
it was like another it was like italian
it was called like italian live had
italian flag on it
well do you think it's trashy if you get
those italian loaves of bread in the
grocery store
the ones in the white bag that's all
class to me that's like as classy as you
can get
like it's always from the local bakery
or something
dude if you're buying individually
wrapped bread fresh bread like that
to me you never use that for sandwiches
though it's always for
when you have spaghetti you chop in or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah of course
slab of butter
we were 100 white bread whether it was
store brand
wonder sometimes store bread
straight down the [ __ ] middle until
we got older
probably maybe like you know high school
then my parents started messing around
with wheat
or you know like seven grain or this or
that or the other thing
but never in the foley house you know
you didn't have beans
never would we have a [ __ ] sandwich
that had that that was wheat bread or
anything
no rye oh yeah rye on saturdays
like rye was a special thing if they
would go and like if my mom or dad would
go to like the
the good deli you know what i mean
senators yeah
instead of getting a lunch meet at the
grocery store yeah when they made one of
those runs on saturdays
remembering lunch on saturdays just all
of a sudden was a home run
there was like a fresh [ __ ] jar of
pickles there was [ __ ] fresh bread
fresh stuff
fantastic came from a broken home
saturdays were the days i was waiting
for my dad to pick me up
you're sitting in a curb somewhere and
i'm at home with two sandwiches
oh yeah getting hugs in the kisses oh
yeah oh yeah
ah that's when the rye bread would come
in and sunday mornings was a big my dad
whenever my dad was running running the
show
rye bread was on the menu always toasted
well yeah toasted rye bread with butter
good night wow that was something else
oh
that was my dad always had fresh rye he
won't blow your hair
my dad always made sure he had a thing
of fresh rye
high seas fruit punch and orange in the
like the boxes
wawa iced tea gold's fish as far as the
eye can see
as far as the like dude it looks like a
supermarket like there would just be
like
a row of six of the cheddar a row with
six of the pretzel
two of the pizzas shout out to the pizza
goldfish by the way
damn i forgot about them until just now
oh man and
talking about the guy behind the guy
those things are fantastic oh yeah
they get the pizzas get you stuck in
here too they're made out of something a
little different that's my favorite part
not just flavoring my favorite part
about cheese snacks is the part that
gets stuck behind your molars
guys that's it thanks for tuning in
everybody
yeah we gotta wrap up anyway really yeah
yeah yeah
i thought there was a question in there
we're talking about rye or something
what was the maple syrup sandwich that
was it yeah all right we can do one or
two more yeah let's do one more
okay i mean all of a sudden i'm the bad
guy no no no stop it
this is from pooty tang i don't know if
it's the real pooty tang or not
uh did you ever stand around the tv
before the news and scream your guesses
at the lottery ping pong balls with your
siblings and then in parentheses we did
i don't i mean we were a big guessing
family we were like a gambler family i
mean
if there was if there was action we
wanted in on it we wanted to be right
that explains why any time there's like
a bit of a mystery on the show your eyes
light up and you're like wait
everybody guess everybody gets oh yeah
we'll do the same thing it's fantastic
yeah yeah yeah
yeah we were guessing that's a real
tragedy
wait don't tell me but they have like
fruit punch around their mouth jumping
around the tv
a couple of bozos uh ones wearing a
diaper way too late
six and still in the diaper that's a
tough look 12 year olds breastfeeding
uh we would always guess i remember one
time he went to like
i think it was busch gardens we went to
busch gardens for the week
in the colonial williamsburg busch
gardens and every time we went out to
eat
we would guess like the change amount or
something
like whatever the bill was if the bill
came to like a hundred
fifteen dollars and thirty two cents at
like lunch or something at lunch dinner
and breakfast it was like a week and we
like just to change
i think something like i remember she
was like trying to guess two numbers i
think it was the change i'm like
guessing would you get to keep that or
something
i think i don't know it was like you won
something my dad my dad used to be
real [ __ ] greasy with the cash like
everybody was getting dogs oh really
oh dude he would have a lot of 20s on
him
like [ __ ] like a baseball dude
[ __ ] everybody
the point where they wouldn't even like
meet you know what i mean like they were
like
it didn't fold in half it folded in like
a quarter you know
uh you must have felt like big [ __ ]
big man on campus
oh yeah a little fat [ __ ] blood a lot
of the mornings it was 20 to go to lunch
and the lunch was like 350 for a [ __ ]
elementary school kid so i was
a [ __ ] 16.50 a day i was about to buy
a motorcycle or something
and save enough for a ducati get paid to
go to school yeah it was great
dude yeah yeah and there was one time
well yeah i'm like yo do you have money
or whatever and he's like what happened
to the change from yesterday i'm like
change from yesterday
that's in my ira you jerk off make good
with the game
i'm sorry is it yesterday am i crazy
um no we would guess as the numbers were
going to be real annoying
like oh my mom's sitting there like
trying to get the number trying to get
to pick four
your mom played she she dabbled a little
bit my brother dabbled a little bit in
the pick four they were big big pick
four pick five people
she never got greedy she'll go for a big
one when it's a big pot you know what i
mean
it's 42 million this week i remember my
stepdad before they were like just state
by st now they're kind of like
everywhere a little weird yeah
my stepdad would be like i'm going to
jersey who needs tickets like when it
was jersey and pa were separate they're
like the mega millions
good guys maybe we would drive to jersey
to buy lottery tickets yeah
good guy credit big jackpot somebody was
in there in
my bodega playing that whatever it's
called the thing that's on the
television there it's done by the
lottery company
or whatever whatever when you're doing
you're classy you're playing that in
there that's a tough look
and they go over to like the side of the
guy like all he he he's
he's part cashier part [ __ ] casino
dealer
sure you know what i mean so they're
doing business aside i swear to god i
hear this lady go let it ride
let it ride you're standing next to
[ __ ]
yeah you're standing next to a pay phone
lady you're not letting [ __ ] right stand
next to pork grinds lady what are you
talking about let it ride
it's a tough look oh gang this has been
a family app
we love you fun one get some ticks come
see the show
do us a solid go over to itunes leave a
little review you know something for the
boys
we're making a sprint here top 100
trying to get in the charts
yeah 106 as of today we'll see 106.
changes every day 106 the hard way too
unlike my underwear shout out to sheep
we love you we'll see you next week
peace